bass aesthetic ways are slippery if
anybody is an able to the stairs the
case allow others to action would before
they go to the fires going for open then
we give you the system's assembly point
moving to public our pockets either the
civics wind please do not do that your
evacuation to checking no please not so
building permission to do so by council
song right um agenda apologies for
absence that's we are discussing on Chad
Lauren is not sure where Jeff is to
learn who i am i would room what
wouldn't be good have a couple of
members public sitting in and they are
slight dilemma here because he's got Lee
made something meeting held on the third
in november and i think i was in
Singapore I can't accident so you have a
to record well II if you want me to take
over chairman I will propose the
dominie's day two of the middie of
further November a true and active
record of what took place on that
evening they're going to grooming thank
you sorry me he's punishing Paige just
that
it's
mm-hmm any declarations of interest as
I'm went okay good item fine welcome Joe
and Nick Thank You chairman um I think I
could we talking about Community Safety
Partnership she said I told ligo
considerable interest to members of the
committee give them these awesome we
should outbreaks of antisocial behavior
around the manor so where would you to
thank you German and in be so careful i
give a brief overview of them csps i
know there are a couple of them newer
members so if i just go through this and
made couple of nights together Rosslyn
Castle Point Community Safety
Partnership were previously known as
crime and disorder reduction
partnerships and their statutory
partnership they were set up from the
crime and disorder Ector of 1998 and at
this baby-smooth secretary partners
these include the police as the
probation service artistry partners from
2007 local authority has helped fire and
the fire rescue food in addition to
these statutory partners and we always
and engage with other partnerships feel
benefit Community Safety Partnership
locally these include of social housing
landlords neighbors watch essex Crime
Stoppers and the Federation of small
businesses and then when we're often
asked our partners to dip in and out of
partnership as well funding has been
considerably
reduced over the last five years funding
for CSP is used to come direct from the
Home Office but now come through the
office of the police and crime
Commissioner wife police and crime
Commissioner Nicholson is very
supportive from the work of the csps the
funding for the 2015-16 year for
ruptured is only 14,000 pounds and
Carson point is slightly more at 17,000
the Community Safety partnerships work
together as part of their community
safety network so this is all Community
Safety partnerships across essex south
and thurrock come together in a wider
group the community safety network
recent topics for some of the working
groups of this group have includes dfk
sorry not da Java domestic homicide
review processes and also exploring
hidden harm cfp partners including
health Fire Rescue please Home Office
representation also come together safer
Essex meetings are higher strategic
level these are usually the Deputy Chief
Constable order to transport in these
meetings these are the wider Essex
meetings again including South End and
tharok so local issues and our local
priorities that we set for the Community
Safety Partnership for the 2015-16 year
are reduced antisocial behavior reduce
violent crime including domestic abuse
reduce dwelling burglary and reducing
reoffending so that gives you a flavour
and i'm just going to earn very much if
you don't mind
that you are and reviewing the work with
the CSP tonight and obviously not direct
police in your shoes which come under
the place thank you any questions on the
overview um excuse me Joe but what's the
the money that's allocated what's the
objective of that what is the target
what would you be spending that on that
money has to be spent in line with the
pc sees priorities that when put down as
ours which are reduced antisocial
behavior reducing violence in crime
including domestic abuse reducing
dwelling burglary and reducing
reoffending and so to give you a couple
of examples and reducing their social
behavior one project is a mediation
service that we deliver we buy into a
mediation service so you've got families
and perhaps creating antisocial behavior
then we can refer them on to that and
with domestic abuse we support sanctuary
scripts game and we've reducing dead
willingboro burberry a lot about it
around public awareness campaigns how we
promote not only what the police doing
but perhaps neighborhood watch and home
safety advice that sort of thing
reducing reoffending we work closely
with the offender management and team
and we also look at projects where we
can make it harder for offenders to
reoffend by providing advice to our
residents something like the type of
event even the small initiatives such as
the first change that we will give out
or they will help to stop people from me
it's the budget use the most units oh
hey yeah yeah yeah okay what so I just
wanted some clarification chairman if I
may through you I'm artist that the
reason for both Kathryn Macpherson being
his mind Nick carbon here tonight were
to answer the questions which becomes
not able to answer at the previous
meeting rather than just a review of the
interview of the CSP so it was more not
just it's not purely just about the CSPs
about the council's response to for
instance letter of the 22nd of June
which i think is we come to be infamous
now is that correct yeah yeah it's that
one thing if thank you for your chairman
just did people get digested to answer
to counsel of a person's point some some
sort of that other general update since
the last meeting so we're in the process
of recruiting the assistant director the
interviews are next week phase one the
week after phase two members so how can
two all being well appoint someone as
soon as possible after that notice
periods permitting they should be
starting sometime the new year I'm sure
we're listening to Pendle notice I've
met with various offices involved graham
Brown who's the antisocial behavior
coordinator and Matt whole white is
helpfully as an assistant director
stepped in to to provide some coverage
and assistance to gray Avenue trip
unfortunately counselor McPherson back
into the portfolio brings with it a lot
of experience we do have a meeting with
the CSP 17th December which will be
attending and there was the training
session skype presentation by the bud by
the police and some of you hopefully
managed to have ten that one we're
hoping that answered some of the
questions that you may have this evening
so so you know perhaps rather than go
through absolutely everything we can
pick up some of the key the key areas
that there isn't something now chairman
it rise from Nick explain practice if we
could cover those that weren't raised at
the presentation that was corn
specifically for lenders and I also know
I attended both for things and hopefully
why not if I had to unfortunately miss
another I think see clash but also we
had to PCC FM with the Chief Constable
not only was there the opportunity to
attend both those events by known at
that PCC event there were many questions
that were put to the Chief Constable
fire email or written so freaking cover
those appoint covered of those certainly
I think when you meet with your
colleagues and castle point what the
[ __ ] around this table also in in what
should one a one doing what is the
answer to the antisocial behavior
problem and there was a lot of
concerning much what about it people are
concerned they definitely want to
important incidence in case they get
targeted themselves and there's also
apparently some sort of issue
the police is where the responsibility
lies and also we were discussing earlier
some of these issues stray from
antisocial behavior into criminal damage
unless I'm very much mistaken he's a
police matter now we do know the police
have got resource problems but it's
becoming an issue that really someone
needs to address because we were saying
earlier if the authorities in quotes
where they might be don't address the
issue the big fear of a lot of people
inside then you start getting the rise
of vigilantes around and then some
people in what sure that you wouldn't
want wandering the streets as vigilantes
and someone's going to get badly hurt if
we don't care and yo you're quite right
chairman and he's a cause of concern and
going back to the letter that the Chief
Constable central local authorities and
he read them himself admitted that he
was a very poorly worded letter at the
PCC meeting that was in October since
then obviously mid-price and as I know
that you followed up with maybe she can
attend
meeting Luke Watson explained that he
wants us all working together there was
to be no the police putting problem on
to us we're going to be working together
which we r do with the antisocial
behavior in rochford there was a meeting
early on the Monday morning and the
police are progressing with
investigations on that obviously I can't
say too much more on that one at moment
I can say that there are several young
people with police orders another as
well you will be helpful for tilling to
the public in general if without
breaking any confidence somebody can
give some examples of what sort of
action can be taken in banning orders as
boat or whatever because I think the
general populace starting anything being
done that's quite right chairman and the
officers coming to the meeting on 44
November and 44 December sorry and at
Rushford I am a meeting with him and the
chairman of parish council before then
so they can clarify what they can say to
the public thing to put the public's
mind of these are the least gives an
explanation of where they are yeah thank
you tune with the we understand about
the problems that you've had in in the
Rochford area I mean there's probably a
little bit of gut feeling that like they
move from John's era in Hawk wall and
once they got moves out Clements all I
don't know but the reality is and having
listened to your cheek inspect
superintendent Collison the other night
I was not convinced that we're working
with part of their working the third
parties as far as I could see it they
were actually on a lot of occasions just
ran the ball into somebody else is
called to deal with the last meeting
when they came with on it seems to us or
seems to me anyway of can't speak the
recipe that we are now on the district
council is at the forefront of is be so
how we going to deal with is B
what was that was our plan what's our I
mean we have the same financial
constraints probably as big as the
police but even bigger so how we go to
address what is at the moment is B but
as we've already decided borders on
criminal damage but if we have to hand
hand is B I believe we have one person
who works four days a week you're quite
right we do have one person who works
four days a week therefore come through
your chair and we have to make sure that
he's working the smartest possible ways
you can possibly work now we will have
i've already made him a dress how many
in social behavior cause he has a long
week ahead 6 3 of those were social
housing tenants therefore we are then
engaging for social housing landlords
and they will deal with that so we can
pass it to them one of those calls was
environmental so he wasn't a change of
social behaviors like and then we had to
but then he's working with the police on
those time but if I my turn but you know
we're playing gun you know we just put
some words here if we have a problem
doesn't matter where it is in the
district Annie's antisocial behavior
food is a resident contact could you
tell me why I'm so surprised you
no that's one of these questions is is
being because the exactly one of the
things I thought prioritize fire new
consumer making space is awareness
campaign with our residents on what is
actually antisocial behavior because i
have sat in a police control room before
when somebody has rang up and said by
the extra length of sawing their trees
down and it's too loud and that's the
sort columns I've been going through to
the place and that is similar to sort of
course that we missing so one we need to
hear awareness with public of what is it
is an anti-social behavior ok so we've
established what is antisocial behavior
and i'm i'm pretty sure when you've sat
down for couple hours you'll still have
a gray area around the edge of it what
is our plan to deal with osb other than
to send a man now it works four days a
week i believe there are more than six
issues of ASB a week in rockford
district they may not be been reported
but i think people really don't know
what to do anymore where to go how to do
it and to be honest and i have an awful
lot of faith that if they do make a
phone call there's going to be any
reaction to it i might be wrong but
thank you for you chairman and i'm very
something else is faring you asked me
what roger was doing about it I told you
how many antisocial behavior across
Russia district councils we've been
received in a week that's not how many
please to proceed that's how many we
have received and that's what we will be
working with I have I agreed but because
the majority of the public don't know
what to do they don't know who to
contact they have no criteria of what is
B is so things are going to put there
may have been two dozen phone calls that
by mistake went to the police rather
than going to bradford district council
if this is what the new criteria is the
police are probably just ignored them I
don't know but because they haven't come
to us with dis
council doesn't mean to say they're not
going on it just means to say that
memory forties so whoever is now the
rival authority and to say we've only
had six okay we've had six but how many
of the police had do we know that I mean
are they passing the month we've had a
conversation earlier this evening where
council amazing myself both in the last
fortnight of reported incidents to 101
numbers that we felt were appropriate
nothing we were both basic each other
okay thanks notice basically for the
fungi I mean I don't want to send it
sort of been but we are now at the
forefront of isb and yep we don't seem
to be okay with us take on a new
assistant director we know that we will
be short but is this really a very
proactive plan for filling this void
appears to be developing of well it's
not the police its eyes very contact the
council what can we do what can the
council do how do we how do we react to
this if if somebody phones at ten
o'clock at night so i've got x y&z going
on and we agree is I speed what can
Brock the district council do if you say
into social behaviour council deals
which which is environmental for example
noise nuisance for example then they
will go through on the only one to six
st. a powerful his numbers and it will
be down with the following day when
somebody's in the office and did you
bring the 101 number up last week of
doing Collison or did councillor nice
and bring it oh if I may injure the
particular event that I've reported to
101 was actually last Tuesday which was
after the presentation indeed it was
after an ECM message that said if you
see anything suspicious or get a
suspicious caller please ring 101
having done so I was less than happy
with the response was basically as
counselors bearing says well thank you
for phoning us but we're not going to do
anything and since then it's been proven
the rather residence had the same sort
of event on their doorstep and they
received the same response but having
explained all of that that's not what
we're talking about here because the
person who was on my door said wasn't an
ASP candidate if you like he was
actually casing my house by calling on
me and he was calling on other people
throughout throughout the area and
that's not to ASB what I would like to
really understand is going back going
back to our counters bearing here today
is what's incidents are for the police
to deal with and so the residents can
call them and reliably convey it to them
with the expectation that they put it in
the right place and which things you
know should go to the 01 268 emergency
number or be dealt with the next day
because at the moment i don't understand
that and I know residents don't either
as I explained we will do an awareness
campaign in partnership with place to
convey to residents exactly what
antisocial behavior is and who deals
with what antisocial behavior think that
we be very helpful suggest using range
of media yes to do that um because
people accessing sort of thing to tell
me like and social media as well as
paper different formats and whatever I
think would be useful may I come back
chair obviously the one-on-one service
is out of our control this is a police
matter
people have issues with the 10 17 days I
have myself and I have reported him and
also if you do report a crime you are
for an instant Loma this is something
that we as members must obviously now
and ask for an instant number and then
you can follow it outside okay you said
you had some answers and one expects me
to go through those now as I said
chairman other in particular point you
want to we want to address that we
didn't want to come to I lick Collison
at the Mediterranean do you think
particularly want to NT Rama yeah wrong
again for the homeless well I'll kick
off if I my children if there is an
issue on a sunday evening at ten o'clock
it is clearly is be basically bradford
district council can't react to monday
morning is that the long and short of it
if it's antisocial behavior that it is
something we will deal with the no we
can't at the moment and do not have the
capacity but my antisocial behavior for
there's a threat or harm to an
individual that goes through to the
place and then it will be dealt with by
then if it's a repeat offenses of
antisocial behavior it goes through to
the place harsh residents don't follow
it up with an instant number because we
need to make sure that those are
recorded because although we work in
partnership with the police I want to
hold them accountable they've had so
many through false in a certain period
of time what they're doing about them
without incident numbers I can't
challenge them so you say that we're
we're working on so what are we going to
do as a council at the pointy end of low
level is be what a week going what's the
plan what is what is our intention are
we going to have a phone number that's
of april twenty answerable 24 hours a
day we have extra is bee staff or where
do we go and thank you very much air
counselor sparing some question and
you've hit our head low libido social
behavior which can become a pain in the
backside foremost our residents we're
talking about litter we're talking about
dog fouling and these are the things
that we are having our officers are
credited for and they will be able to go
out and they will send a clear message
show residence and be able to give out
fixed penalty fines we're going to work
out on the model of the malden district
council have if you like ze tells them
in please look them up then run the skin
for over 12 years now it's been warmly
welcomed by the residents and it's your
low-level antisocial behavior it's sort
of that question why brambles oiling up
still I think it's been asked three
times so far about what is antisocial
behavior and I think three times has
been told that there'll be a campaign to
leverage that that's over years bill we
are being we would like to know now if
you can give us a few more company you
can help founding and litter Android out
of three um that's fine and that would
be dealt with by the council you say
which is the soaring down the tree which
you gave example but there is a view
that somewhere things have changed I'm
not aware that within my walls that the
place would ever have come out for Doc
failing or litter in any case that would
have always been a council issue as far
as I'm concerned for as long as I've
been counselor so I don't think that has
changed my big concern is what what has
changed with the letter of the
twenty-second of June if nothing has
changed then I don't see that we have to
change but the view that I seem to get
is that something has changed the police
seem to think something has changed by
their lecture and sweating in June
it concerns concerns me that we don't
seem to have enacted anything to take
account that if you're going to tell us
that nothing has change from that
natural 26 jun little i presume that
there's not too much or probably carry
on as we were rather questions thank you
Kevin I think so if you may cancel hide
the minis from the BBC meeting when I
personally asked the Chief Constable of
our lab nectar I'm supported by every
single Council that was around that
table that that was a poorly worded
answers it is not the case that the
police are not doing English have ninety
two percent or whatever the percentage
was very high of antisocial behavior how
it should read is a highly centage of
calls thinking about antisocial behavior
or not antisocial behavior or their
antisocial behavior that should be dealt
with by the local authority and trust me
people do we have about dog fouling they
will ring up because their neighbors are
having a barbecue in the summertime
anti-social behaviour with Renee to
noise music nuisance will go up because
younger ball be out and about not all of
them are causing antisocial behavior I
think if I couldn't just come back on
that it yes obviously I've read the
minutes he didn't say as much as you
said in the minutes obvious it said it
was poorly worded not much beyond that
so they are saying there for that they
are not doing anything less than they
did before can you confirm that you know
if you listen two minutes I'm not the
written a minutes that's why I put a
link on your listen to the Chief
Constable apologizing for that letter
went out and say how he wants us all to
be working together for the benefit of
people who are here who listen to all
members of the public who made listen to
the recording of this meeting and not
have a link via the the voice could you
state whether or not the letter of the
sweater second of june will or will not
do less than was done before you I'm
getting the impression that you're
saying that it it's all good saying is
it with you they're gettin calls which
they should really get
they were still they were still dealing
with antisocial behavior as they've
always dealt with it the police have
explained they will deal with antisocial
behavior where there's a threat a harm
or repeat appearances I'd is that the
same as they have always dealt with it
as far as i know i think the other issue
that concerns people is it doesn't
appear to be any sanctions against the
perpetrators of these issues and to
quote one of my residents are getting
more praising by the day and when
they've moved on you can call it moving
on from throwing doc Mesa people's house
windows to throwing stones and moving
cars which is it it goes through a
windscreen and hits a driver it's got
potential home talk to do and that that
must be quitting daddy trinity knot and
they will come out to those and chairman
because there's a threat harm somebody
as well as i'm tryna them but I'm to get
their kids have gotten somewhere else
and several of those people that you're
referring to in the area are on gorgeous
yes and going back to council of ice
question is just a shame stone
counselors couldn't have actually have
asked that question to the police
themselves when they had the opportunity
both of Luke Ronson he's maintained that
he gave to all members here and also the
TCC event a few days later we had two
events in this district and I'm afraid
not everybody went to them hi find me to
do safety is very important people
should be there personally so the next
week team uses the 14th of them that's a
local placing one in rochford I'm sure
that if either house alar oil councillor
mace now i'm not sure if anybody else
unfortunately missed the two events or
put on specifically for this area but
I'm sure they can come there and ask the
police question will be quite a
reasonable turnout from the public yes
shall we say
okay moving on so are there any other
issues people wonder what a twist I
think chairman I mean I'm still a bit
confused as to where we as a district
council will be moving to how we will I
mean if our total involvement and going
back to Council always comment if their
total involvement is in relation to dope
mess well then okay i can understand we
only need one person but even the other
night we've inspected Chief
Superintendent Collison that was not the
impression I got from him that you know
this is the sort of issues that the
district council will be the gleam with
the way obviously must remind
misunderstanding but the way I
understood it was no you are the legal
authority on on isb and it wasn't just
took the implication was it was not just
the sort of level that you've talked
about I don't know if other people felt
the same I felt I certainly felt that
the parameters had moved the bar had
moved up our responsibility our
requirement to become involved have
moved up a few notches I agree if we're
having we I made the point to him that
we do not have the power of arrest and
it just went quietly no comment came
back and that really was the end of my
that was a total response I got to a
question about working with third
parties what are we supposed to do how
we supposed to act what can we do what's
our area of responsibility I won't by
the way we can't arrest anyone so where
did we all fit in nothing came back
nothing's coming back now
please hey I've seen that clearly
explained to new person and two
chieftains they're comfortable all
Steven Cavanaugh we as a council do not
have a capacity to take on the work of
the place we will work together on
issues we will not take responsibility
of the police's wrong and my own to say
chairman it would be I know there's a
lot of focus on antisocial behavior
tonight I mean not one question and the
recent domestic homicide that we will be
involved in close we would you think you
14,000 pounds allocated to rupture to
17,000 pounds to castle point in 3,000
pounds difference is how is that
allocated how is that decided that
castle point get 3,000 pounds more than
we do I had a population if I had a
population so that is 14,000 pounds that
we've got to use in rochford to reduce
anti-social behavior violent crime
including domestic abuse reoffending and
dwelling burberry so with that money is
going to education more than anything
else I mean that is a massive reduction
over the last I know you said that over
the last five seven years that is some
roughage Court of all you stress and
yeah is there any way we can get funding
from elsewhere and there is I am a
bearing in mind at the moment we have
one officer part-time four days a week
but yes and one of the
something that he did apply for was the
texture natural scheme to dress
antisocial behavior in Raylan having him
success all of them he was successful
because that seems me monies is
obviously a factor here when we're
trying to do with your problems in our
district and you said the small small
businesses Crimestoppers neighborhood
watch nobody's or if we inviting a park
past of it it does appear to me that
perhaps we should be trying to raise
funds from from from other areas because
it is it's in the interest of all our
residents to be having these funds to
help with that I'd like to see if we
click look at getting simpleton Mouse
where does mine yes sorry thank you it's
either turn McConnell Castle McPherson
you talk about working together morgut
obviously we were when we favor all I
think there's been a lack of that over
the years it sounds like we come up back
to the place you've sent them to of the
schools for instance with the in dealt
with by the place in conjecturing graham
Brown what have we met directly I not
just through the CSP how we met directly
with the place to see how better we can
work together such as referring 101
course which might relate to what we
would deal with rather than what the
police would deal with to us are we the
president are you able to do that
following a recent incident before the
one on sunday and of anti-social
behaviour in an area and the police the
social housing land
God and our offices met the following
morning at 9am and orders were put in
place I was that was for a specific
innocent yes I was talking more
generally there are we talking to the
place for a way that the 101 calls can
be referred on a regular basis if they
relate to what so something that we
would be dealing with normally or is
that happen anyway thought is that
that's something that we know the
community safety Network come together
that's the sort of thing that we need to
discuss as a group but in lobby the PCC
again I hate to harp on but if people
had gone to the PCC event and which is
recorded so you can listen to the
questions and you can instance the
answers there were a lot of questions on
the 101 numbers and a lot of answers
there are going to be new ways of in the
game ha Australians please and remit but
opening new ways of they bringing in for
example an app so you will get an
instant incident number so you will have
a record of your poem mmm I was trying
to really get special with whether we
are being proactive or reactive to the
police I thought of Ben where of the app
i think it was suggested many years ago
over them so has been bit delayed so
through the network yes we will be
lobbying but are we
but are you has this being discussed
within the network whose paths pose as
once a pet dog these are genuine to do
that that's what's needed or are there
other things I thank genitori we come
together again at the same for Essex
network which senior police officers are
there we work on various projects are
coming in such as the hidden home games
that are coming in from loans and some
of the issues we are fellow have talked
about but one of them for example is the
101 number and the ECM messaging and
when we are pushing for these to be
improved because it is the new way
people should be able to contact the
police on the phone on the internet and
through text messaging all forms even
through social media and that is what
the police are investigating air to make
it easiest possible way for people to
report crime yes I think you um and then
we are we talking a lot tonight about
the police's response to to the
low-level crime old or crime and
anti-social behavior but in the cs pain
there are a number of people on CSP
probation and as you use offending as
well a plant parcel of that now one of
the targets is reducing reoffending now
that's not necessarily a police issue
but say we do talk about the place a lot
but that would be um i suggest a
probation a youth offending
responsibility to help with the
reoffending and and perhaps even with
the domestic violence issues as well
that they want
so are they doing anything specific are
they aware of the concerns we have about
this now they are they targeting
anything particularly now in our area
yeah and there's great projects that
they are due to engage with people we
had recently officiant project there'll
be things like the firebreak forces i
will send young people on so you can
monitor their improvement and they also
work closely with each other Fenton and
they asked him in school and work
closely with the school or transfer them
out the area for schooling and there is
also things such as the budding and
tagged scheme that people can engage
themselves in there are a lot there's a
lot of why they go on we have the
reports maxius pays for PP f er sorry
for system prolific offenders you're
just at the cns piece so I know we will
tend to sort of take this is
responsibility of the police but there
are other organizations that have other
responsibilities for that these takata
that we have sadist went to make sure
they were doing their bit just on the
probation and time as well and offending
looking at some of these ppos you will
find that they will migrate around the
county so again when the community
safety networks come together often
people come into even Rochefort have
coming from south end and both of us and
we will talk to each other done Thank
You Sharon because I'm a person you
refer to something earlier by
criticizing us for not raising something
that you thought we should and it
involved a homicide can you tell us more
about that please everyone should be
aware that we will you know where joint
CSP Queen to safety
and there was a recent domestic murder
on Canvey Island from the Home Office it
is down to the CSP to leave that review
now the good thing interactions anything
they review when we joined as a merge
CSP we kept our separate identities so
we work together on that domestic
homicide review but it will also comes
with a large price tag to the local
authority who foots the bill and reviews
but what we want to gain from this is we
need to learn from this experience
because the last thing that we want here
in our district is everything what's
happened that poor lady on handling yeah
i'm just-just andrew say sorry Michael
and and has the nicest of a puzzle no
I'm not puzzled I'm concerned that such
an event as that is considered to be so
very local that we must take an
immediate action whereas in fact our
thought who've been in a real
sub-regional regional and national and I
just I just think I'd never heard of
such a thing happening before certainly
not in this in this area area including
castle point yet a low and outside of
outside of that so I was quite shocked
so we are going to have to do some work
on that it's going to cost money why
isn't that funded nationally because
surely this is a national issue FDA
Charles are and they are a national
every single local authority
you have a domestic homicide within your
district he is down to the district to
create her carry out there if you
through the CSP and fund it whoo look at
her way like Halle they have had three I
believe in the last year so that's a lot
of fun so this is where a lot of the
preventative work we've done human
Rochford around j9 project and the
things that I find equally as important
if not more than a necessity havea are
worth and our investment in our time so
there's been three and Harlow there must
be a lot of learnings they're all this
review to pick up on yes so Harlow's
involved in presumably there are other
clusters and events around the country
and all those reviews will be included
at nationally yes they are and just
curiously the relationship between say
406 in the local of CSP it's really been
alluded to that the funding that comes
the CSB has been stashed five
seventy-five percent over the last four
or five years so work is being carried
out by the local CSP is obviously a lot
less than it was veneers gone by safer
Essex has with replicated much of that
work at county level obviously has a
strategic overview I guess my question
is is there still a role for the local
CSP because of that the resource of its
extra bonuses be having Saturn many CSPs
myself I know how resource intensive Lee
I know the amount of work that goes on
but without pot of funding being shrunk
to fifteen sixteen thousand pounds does
it still worn the CSP to actually
deliver that would that be better done
at a safe Wessex level because already
the PCC is it's in charge of the high
noon
that where we're going as a district or
do you still see those being involved
with local CSP I hope it stays the local
CSP the say forensics is a more
strategic view so it will look at things
that are impacting on Essex making and
we may have a presentation on terrorism
on gangs drugs at that level as a
strategic level house ESP looks at our
local issues and that's what we want to
deal with here locally I think if it
moved away from the local responsibility
we won't be able to work with some of
their really good local small brass
bridge projects that we do do that you
know make a difference don't think
anybody went to download a domestic
homicide it's just that antisocial
behavior seems to be problem for all of
us London is exciting their local
communities and also people because as I
said earlier lot reason let's amazing
that's getting very Braves and people
are not looking forward to the school
holidays because you know these are
stones in shop windows in dark we're now
doing it in broad daylight and so the
school holidays coming up people are
getting a bit concerned that something
you've got to be done I totally bring a
chair and the problem is you have to
realize at the moment we only have fun
mercies like you four days away we have
nobody so he's looking monitor the
reporting the monitoring of things
basically and everything at the moment
it looks after wire one pattern overseen
by chance so it's our dreams JP throwing
stones at cars he's not low-level
installation so I don't think that's for
us and how am I jump the gun about this
review of why I as Ben's idea that
doesn't strike me that strikes me as as
a threat at home it is it is all right
good any further questions to you just
one more you've said about we had to
review this this murder what do we have
to review and that certain procedures
and practices are in place by whom by
all the partners who will have coming to
and contact and worked with that person
so if the police had knowledge of it
we're going to investigate the police
are we and it will be a review it's not
an investigation it's a review okay what
what you have you blame anybody / if you
will see the processes and who's worked
rather person and if there are gaps
where that person should have been
working by certain organization more is
going to be highlighted and we know and
who will lead on this I'm optimist the
chair of the CX pain but there yet
decided on that by meeting on 17 /
December my going for lower prices this
way or the left in the chair and who
will simpler review Oh yummy so can I
chair details of domestic home size of
views from the home office and house
it could even find that helpful to yell
at him hi I'd certainly wheelchair
because I don't quite know what what
we're going to glean from it the as you
say we've had one in I don't know how
many years what what experience what
what we can glean are we going to if
there was a wreck or if there is is this
what it is tell you when you say review
you actually do investigate that
everything was done there should have
been done in the sunset or or could it
be that this was just a one-off argument
between a couple that became out of hand
and very regrettably somebody died out
of this scenario but I mean I'm not
saying trying to minimize this in any
way shape or form but what are we going
to do once we've reviewed this where we
go with this couple of things yeah are
also circulate a previous dear child
view with the findings from it and
improvements that and the things that
could have been done to possibly prevent
nature sometimes you can't but sometimes
they could be recent and you may recall
and a wire quite warm back and when I
had the CSP before I circulate to the
wrong movie everybody is familiar with
the reference
from that we were to Castle Point
Council and we delivered some training
prior taxi drivers because if you
actually read the review and the
findings they felt that info taxi
drivers some of them had known what to
look for and the swordfish aboard young
lady in the back of the car it doesn't
look quite right food to be able to
report back to so when given that
training to our taxi drivers back so now
I'm really pleased that we've done and
that's the whole determing thing that
comes from these reviews you see you can
see well actually if that was in place
it might not have happened it seems to
me that you look to the issues but
there's still more to be done not
particularly with new people coming on
board it also seems to me if you've got
someone doing this wrong maybe he or she
he isn't it and could be assisted by
someone that has a clerical level to do
some of the record-keeping to release
him to go out and play and try to roll
in the community to have a the community
safety officer who's spending these fun
the paperwork someone else would be
doing that and but also you're going to
get a new assistant director from what
I'm saying so I think unless anybody
else has got any further questions I
think we like that you can come back in
a few months time and see how the new
world looks just have one question go on
just go back to the young six calls to
graham Brown 13 which you said were
relating to and housing associations I
think both you and I know and mainly
transcripts as well that one of them did
have a vacancy for nice be opposite you
know if that's being filled or not and
in there as far as I know you know if I
and but we now know from the balance
meeting kingdom I come back for them I
don't know if your sign he counts I
heard momentum no it's all so long ow I
social behavior officer again I
mentioned about the some of the staff
were going to be credited when I'm
afraid social behavior officers also be
appreciative but he's going to be
working out the half the hub will being
a patron police station so far closer
contact with the police to be named
liaison on a day-to-day basis and a lot
of the issues facing environment and
this is right i mean about as for
working together and it's going to be
difficult on the girls ages and i'm not
going to let a place be lumbering us
with things that are there it's not
often that a vice versa we're willing to
help them but we are limited with
capacity and that's the truth ok ok one
last questions thank you Jim and apart
from the thing with in with can be the
review we're going to do Internet can be
other benefits for you have my joints
ESP always come from quite a few tea and
some of the projects we run across both
areas and it also cuts down I've always
really have a lot of partners who will
be sitting in two separate meetings so
we can to give good work together at the
moment again a little bit why we're
value go for ahem I know that basically
out of the goodness of their heart the
CSP team have been keeping up with some
of the monitoring in the fall
that we need to do which normally week
will be share and some of the training
they and one of their officers had she
did not remember laying there but it's a
very intense training on identifying
extremists which is very useful
knowledge from us to have as well but I
know for us to ask because that office
has gone on that train training yes
there we are thinking to team to do work
together though I think what it would
again anything up what kind thank you
both for coming and we we I don't know
about you so we look forward to seeing
you again in a few months when the new
processes have bedded down the new staff
are in place and seeing if we can take
the discussion further forward I would
urge that when you do without the
publicity if you can say there are
sanctions that can be taken against
individuals and possibly describe them
without naming individuals I think that
would be a reassurance or lots of us and
the public would be sealed the action
but don't actually see what I do love a
social insane Lisbon and actually is
being taken against the individuals of
chopped down between and because they
were seeing and I'm told it was three
o'clock in the morning the Parish
Council is happy to to prosecute and
therefore the police are taking some
action now hope you that message will
get around but anything else that can be
done and we all know housing
associations have a power to a big
people of antisocial behavior please all
except one inbox which apparently
doesn't have that in their contracts I
know I'm not going to know what I'm
gonna say yeah
you got buns away if you shout at you
talking might be a tad more robust than
that lipton nevermind and thank you
again and we'll see you then Paul this
use of salsa music ending would you
advise them aight guys i stole them and
I asked if I could have some spares
thank you thank you very much cruising
over if anybody would like to them you
know don't need to ask more questions
always just ask and I thought I take you
in an institution officer at 172 overly
sweet more items the key decision
document like to come with an informant
right okay and to keep certain documents
it's go on three items on it the first
one the home strategies has been on
there since June it's going back I'm
told now this time is in government
golly going so this decision will be
made early next year then the next one's
a palm tree sector grants which is the
annual decision noticed some members
will wake up their folders with all the
details and that's going to be December
and then finally the newest one and
memorandum of understanding it's an
agreement between ourselves and county
on the glittery of enforcement action
from sections 24 25 than the main
drainage act and it comes about things
like four and work has begun on cam cars
question about the first one which is
though my 15 provide 15 is is that to be
expected to be doubled by the housing
and planning actress the bill that's
currently progressing for is that or is
it some other means ie I only know from
what Sean told me today there's changes
in government guidelines I couldn't
actually tell my weekend but I could up
and ask and find out I think I would be
interested because you know looking
about and looking at the risk of not
taking action you know seems rather
rather less remote and it actually very
pointed and if I'd like to know whether
it's our expectation whether the housing
and planning acts or the bill that's
progressing were in fact that deal is I
think from what I've read of a few
bullet points it looks like it could but
I don't know that for sure further
comments on that bottom ok the other
document then it is being to work plan
for this committee the next you know
obviously have another meeting without
friends in the community safety
partnership will have to readd it and
what I was going to suggest is if
there's any items anybody feels very
strongly should be included and armed
that they email pull and pull and
discuss and see if we could hit me all
the time but you also now Bengie Safety
Partnership is booked put in for the
first two marches where is it well
spotted let's think
how do you work tell you for now oh well
done cool ok so people want to look at
this event took their leisure and then
can touch with Paul and if they thinking
that people think should be on there is
not and most here to the infinity people
will find somewhere shouldn't speak of
Bernie will be doing missions fine in
January given my perturbation gets worse
sorry nice trying to my name is John 12
and 0 visionaries behind you how are you
nice to [ __ ] you true right I think
that's anybody has any other business
this is us darling you don't wanna make
it makes me wish all a good festive see